good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is scp-1554 siege errs
all adult
scp-1554 by 5 meter by 5 meter terrarium
simulating desert conditions under
electronic surveillance and implanted
with tracking devices an event of an
escape the affected sector will be
locked down until all specimens have
been recaptured as CP 1550
are to be kept in their airtight
packaging apart from in testing the
total population of scp-1554 specimens
being terminated and their corpses
incinerated all testing must be approved
by level 3 staff or higher all
uncontained instances of scp-1554
the scription item scp-1554 deficiencies
of unknown classification whose larvae
have the ability to undergo
metamorphosis into a form which is
adapted for their environment
however despite adaptations all
specimens possess a tattoo like set of
markings on their underbelly reading a
doctor wonder tame at trademark and none
will grow to over centimeters in length
due to scp-1554 form and if so what it
is SCP 1550s eggs are 1 centimeter long
flesh-toned avoids which will only hatch
if exposed to air
when packaged they are stored under
airtight plastic seals apparently for
transport dissection of unhatched eggs
reveals them to simply contain a
biological mucoid substance containing
fragmentary DNA
unknown origin as adult 1550 specimens
appear to be sterile it is unknown how
the eggs are created this is scp-1554
scp-1554 siege er one scp-1554 and
allowed to hatch results SCP 1557
scp-1554
her back and behind the eyes flattened
and brought in tails to serve as paddles
for swimming and produces specialised
mucus to protect its eyes from salt
damage it has a swim bladder revealed
upon dissection in its logo and notes
skin coloration was also a mottled blue
presumably to blend in with the seawater
doctor
test subject scp-1554 c jure one
scp-1554 a river behind cycle in which
scp-1554 dand allowed to hatch results
SCP 1557 scp-1554 thinned body for
increased streamlining notes no gills
apparently it doesn't use the same
adaptations for similar circumstances
that's somewhat odd dr. Poole test
subject scp-1554 c jure one scp-1554
forest ecosystem and allowed to hatch
results SCP 1557 SCP 15:53 has a thin
layer of brown fur covering the top of
its body and a ridged snake-like
underbelly as well as enlarged tail
tentacles notes the ridges along a CP
1550 - threes underbelly had a small
oval patch of smooth skin on which the
tattoo like markings were located dr. P
test subject scp-1554 C jure one
scp-1554
results scp-1554 was cold-blooded and
has a tanned coloration to camouflage it
against sand as well as a tendency to
burrow notes the size was also
interesting centimeters in length about
one centimeter larger than the other
specimens dr. T test subject scp-1554 C
jure one scp-1554 areum made to simulate
a standard city apartment and allowed to
hatch results a CP 1550 - 5 has leathery
skin eyes on short lumps protruding from
its head in a manner somewhat like the
eyes of a chameleon and was noted for
behaving in a more affectionate and
active manner to researchers than other
specimens of scp-1554 look at strands of
whale-like Bailey allowing the specimen
to filter out dust and crumbs on the
floor
dr.
test subject scp-1554 siege er one
scp-1554 tonight results SCP 1550
into flames and was destroyed notes well
what did you expect to happen doctors
test subject scp-1554 siege ER one
scp-1554 which was then depressurized
results SCP 1550
coating the inside of the vacuum chamber
in notes it now seems obvious that
scp-1554 t'v complex animal can live so
we might as well stop trying to make
them do so dr test subject scp-1554
siege ER one scp-1554 which was then
pressurized to 1086 bars 15,750 psi
results scp-1554 a bioluminescent lure
similar to that of an anglerfish
extending from its forehead gills
similar to scp-1554 and a dark grey blue
coloration legs were flattened and
webbed into fish like fins and eyes were
nearly twice the size of those of other
scp-1554 sharpened and possessed ridges
to cut meat similar to those found in
many species of shark
notes this leaves the question of just
what kind of child doctor wonder
tainment is trying to sell these things
to that would live in conditions were a
creature like that could be kept as a
pet doctor history ASAP 1550 was brought
into containment after a series of 10
cardboard packages printed with stylized
images of 1550 specimens and the words
doctor Wonder Taemin's custom pets
trademark each containing six scp-1554
ten struction leaflet was found in the
exotic pet section of the pets door upon
interrogation of store workers it was
proven that none possessed knowledge of
scp-1554 scp-1554 packaging hey kids
your parents aren't letting you get a
dog or cat don't fret by a doctor wonder
tainment custom pet trademark doctor
wonder taemin's custom pets trademark
are far superior to an ordinary boring
cat or dog due to their original adapt
Oleg's trademark packaging a dr wonder
tainment invention just leave your
custom pet trademark adapt Oleg's
trademark around the house and when they
hatch they'll fit right in perfect for
apartments to get your very own custom
pets trademark is easy kids just put an
egg in your house and break the plastic
seal to give your new pet some air so it
can hatch your new pet will be perfect
for where you live wherever you live if
your new custom pet trademark seems
lonely just add another adapt away
trademark and get them a new friend
warning for parents please monitor your
children's placement of adapt oinks
trademark to prevent dr. wonder tainment
is not responsible for injuries or death
caused by this or any other product dr
wonder Taemin's custom pets trademark
are shipped pre neutered
Wow I need one of these things I'm
serious
I need one of these things you know how
lonely I get you guys are the only
people that I get to talk to this would
be fantastic
I would love a pet shark well I suppose
it wouldn't really turn into a shark but
I wonder what it would turn into if I
put it into soup a chicken soup what
about if I hatched it next to a TV would
it get like really big eyes so we could
see the TV perfectly
oh I have so many ideas okay we got to
wrap this up so I can try and find one
of these things thank you all for
listening if indeed you still are and
you were all dismissed goodbye
[Music]
I would like to give a special thank you
to Pierce M Hamlin Muslim Mookie slump
God dr. day John Oh quarter
captain Gorge fluffy sky key mana moon a
my archive curator neck tie verbal hoody
tench
cheese whip I'm Depp's McGee thank you
all so much for your support I really
appreciate it if you would like a
special thank you at the end of each of
my videos on some other cool stuff as
well is it patreon.com forward slash the
vulcan thank you
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]